à écouter tout le monde un autre sujet
qui va peut-être pas améliorer le moral
des français si ce projet aboutit
françoise nyssen à midi de la culture il
ya quelques semaines avait évoqué l'idée
d'augmenter la taxe sur la redevance
télévisée elle pose pour être plus
précis l'idée qu'elle et qui avait été
abandonné et oran berger qui est député
la république en marche mais qui est
surtout l'auteur d'un rapport sur
l'avenir de l'audiovisuel est revenu à
la charge c'était ce matin sur rtl pour
elle tout le monde doit payer la
redevance télé même ceux qui n'ont pas
la télé
déjà on consomme pas la télé forcément
devant un téléviseur il ya une cohérence
avoir déjà face aux avancées
technologiques
puis une forme d'équité aussi à avoir
aujourd'hui c'est surtout les csp + par
exemple qui paye pas la redevance parc
parce qu'il regarde la télé non pas
devant un téléviseur mais devant leurs
tablettes ou avec leur smartphone par
les allées nicolas bouzou encore un
nouvel impôt vous répondez à ma place je
pensais qu'il n'avait pas de nouveau non
mais vous voyez là on est vraiment face
à un problème à mon avis gravissime
comment vous les lundis des grands
problèmes de la politique économique
dans ce pays c'est qu'elle n'est pas
crédible mais s'est pas allié à ce
gouvernement c'est quelque chose qu'on
connaît depuis extrêmement longtemps
parce que il ya en permanence des
signaux contradictoires et notamment sur
la fiscalité
tous les présidents de la république en
tout cas à l'e3 dernier manuel macron
françois hollande et nicolas sarkozy ont
à chaque fois quasiment juré sur leurs
dieux qu'il n'y aurait pas de nouveaux
impôts pas de création d'impôts et deux
ou trois jours après on a réapparition
d'un impôt d'une taxe était et ce
gouvernement est en train de tomber dans
ce panneau
donc comment voulez-vous ensuite que les
gens je reviens à mon histoire de taxe
d'habitation j'en fais pas une obsession
mais les gens se disent ben on nous
supprime la taxe d'habitation à c'est
pour mieux nous reprendre de l'argent
ailleurs il le problème c'est que je ne
suis pas en capacité de leur donner tout
à fait tort quand j'entends leurs
bergers qui est une amie une personne
charmante par ailleurs voilà sauf que
c'est pas décidé pour l'instant
et puis les parlementaires de la
majorité ça valait médiatique qui avait
connu c'est déjà la deuxième tentative
après celle de françoise nyssen eric
écouter cet argument quand même il est
assez recevable aujourd'hui les gens
regardent aussi la télévision sur l'or
sur leur pc sur leurs tablettes sur leur
smartphone
donc il est logique de faire payer tout
le monde mais pour
rejoindre ce que vous avez dit en effet
de sens alors effectivement c'est un
ballon d'essai je pense que c'est pas
gratuit
elle lance ça pour voir la polémique
voir comment ça va ça va prendre et puis
on viendra mais pourquoi pas une taxe
sur le tabac pour les non fumeurs parce
que quand on est quand on reçoit ce à la
con et simples citoyens qu'on n'a pas on
ne comprend rien alors après vous pouvez
me justifier autant que vous voudrez
mais oui vous avez un ordinateur pour
regarder la télé mais j'entends ça quand
on parle que c'est d'abord de la
confiance c'est d'abord une impression
le pouvoir d'achat c est ce qu on a ce
qu'on se sent les moyens de pouvoir
acheter
eh bien là c'est désastreux
effectivement ce que vous dites et ben
oui taxes sur le tabac ce n'est pas
fumeur une taxe sur l'essence on n'a pas
de voiture et sert à ccc désastreux
alors j'ajoute quelques chiffres donc la
redevance ses 139 euros par foyer et il
y à 73 % des foyers fiscaux qui la paye
ça veut dire à peu près un français sur
quatre qui déclare au moment de payer sa
taxe d'habitation qui n'a pas la
télévision et que donc il ne la paye pas
daniel bilalian vous avez été l'un des
piliers du service public télévisuel en
france est ce que vous voyez cette
réforme d'un bonnet si elle permet
d'apporter plus d'argent alors france
télévisions non ce qui était justifiée
la rue de vence de mon temps pour me
voir il faut l'essayer mais on ya vécu
ça avec eux sûrement conscient que cette
possibilité-là javier prochaine de
télévision quatre chaînes avec tf1 donc
il n'y avait rien de plus normal et puis
les choses étaient simples les gens
aiment les choses simples avant quand
vous alliez acheter votre poste de
télévision pour amplifier un papier et
le banc d'heure de pause de télévision
vous déclarer au fisc et vous receviez
une redevance c'était pas plus compliqué
comment laisser penser que des jeunes
aujourd'hui face à leurs smartphones qui
ont des abonnements à netflix à droite à
gauche vont payer une redevance c'est
une couillonnade de dire ça comment même
pour quand un ballon d'essai et alors je
parle pas du reste c'est on va supprimer
la publicité sur france radio france
mais on va rajouter la publicité sur
france 2 le soir pendant cinq ans
pourquoi cinq ans on sait pourquoi
enlever c'était pour faire plaisir à
brigue de la part de sarkozy bon n'y
revenons pas c'est pas ça s'est passé
comme ça s'est passé comme ça non mais
je veux dire on est au niveau d' âneries
que justement ces jeunes députés qui
arrive de
man ma on sent que ce sont pas des
politiques pour sortir des choses comme
ça ce sont pas des politiques c'est bien
ça le problème et des âneries s'en
sortent toutes les semaines un faisable
ça c'est un faisable ce qu'elle a dit il
ou comment vous allez expliquer un gamin
de 18 ans qui a trois téléphones qui est
toute la journée branché que il faut
qu'ils payent une redevance la redevance
et 1958 pour voir général de gaulle
pointe à la ligne droite avec michel
jobert c'est l'époque c'est l'époque où
la télévision publique que témoin de
gauche
aujourd'hui donc on avait plus envie de
la regarder là c'est un témoignage
personnel que je vois si vous voulez
savoir
la télévision publique a été sous là non
pas la menace mais était très dit
l'avait dirigé par le gouvernement
jusque dans les années moi je connais
bien ça puisque la cohabitation de 86 a
mis un terme à la puissance publique à
la télévision
la vraie liberté des journalistes de
télévision ces 86 entre chirac et
mitterrand
là ça a été fini on faisait semblant
d'écouter l'un pour ne pas écouter
d'autres et donc c'était ça s'est
terminé selon là on a retrouvé notre
entière liberté ce qui n'avait pas
toujours été ce qu'elle même si même si
sur certains médias du service public
je pense à france inter par exemple on a
surtout la liberté d'être de gauche en
tout cas c'est ce que ressent l'auditeur
mais c'est encore c'est un avis
personnel
est ce que c'est une bonne idée de
gauche je dirais bien pensants est ce
que c'est une bonne idée de d'élargir la
redevance télévisée 78 % de nos
internautes trouvent que non 1 c'est
votre point de vue sur twitter on nous
dise tu écris pourquoi ne pas proposer
d'être dispensé de redevances en échange
de ne pas recevoir les chaînes publiques
gens debout nous dit taxes taxes airtag
stop ça suffit
anti mac sur lefigaro.fr nicolas bouzou
a raison c'est une nouvelle taxe par
semaine ou presque et sur lefigaro.fr
encore guillaume à quand la taxe pour
respirer l'air ambiant qui nous entoure
guillaume bernard à ce que vous n'avez
pas envie de soutenir le gouvernement ou
la majorité sur ce sujet parce qu'il ya
les points de vue sont presque
convergent qu'il y ait d'abord qui dit
redevance 10 usages
c'est quand même un élément extrêmement
important et donc que parce que l'on à
lusage
chaînes publiques on est à payer ses
chaînes publiques directement ou
indirectement à la limite pourquoi pas
oui
finalement je les défends peut-être un
tout petit peu en revanche moi je
voudrais mettre le doigt sur une
question la redevance et de aujourd'hui
240 x 139 euros
mais pour combien de chaînes on a besoin
de x chaîne de radio 2 x chaînes de
télévision publiques - public
quelle est la justification de
l'existence de toutes ces chaînes et de
tout c'est de toutes ces radios
à la limite si les gens acceptent encore
aujourd'hui deux pays 139 euros c'est
que inconsciemment ils pensent que c'est
pour avoir la télévision sur leur disais
que c'est uniquement pour les chaînes
publiques je suis pas sûr qu'ils
paieraient aussi facilement je pense que
les gens pensent si cher et aussi cher
je pense que les gens les gens en
général pense que c'est pour avoir la
télé voilà pour cette chaîne publique
qui diffuse la comédie française
moi ça m'irait très bien nicolas bouzou
est ce que l'économiste libéral que vous
êtes considèrent comme justifiées qui
est un service public de cette taille en
france où le service public de
télévision oui je pense que c'est tout à
fait justifiée il y en a dans tous les
pays du monde et certains sont très
qualitatif en au royaume uni la bbc
c'est quand même une très belle
une très belle réussite donc non en
revanche mais ça je crois que c'est ce
que le président de la république a à
l'esprit
il ya évidemment trop de chaînes ya trop
de chaînes publiques y en a certaines
qui sont tout à fait tout à fait
confidentiel et ça coûte quand même
assez cher et la redevance est
relativement élevé donc je pense qu'il
faut rationaliser sa mais bien qu'étant
libéral je suis quand même pragmatique
donc je n'achète pas l'idée selon
laquelle on pourrait imaginer une
télévision complètement privé il ya très
peu très peu de pays dans lesquels ça
existe
rick d'écouté vous trouvez quatre autres
chaînes dans l'audiovisuel plus aussi
évident c'est évident et des chaînes qui
sont d'ailleurs je crois que sais je
sais plus laquelle j'ai oublié le nom le
chiffre c'est la 4 qui l'incarnent qui a
dit warcq dérisoire face et ce quelques
centaines de milliers de téléspectateurs
qui la regardent donc effectivement moi
je trouve que le service public
il est plutôt de qualité je suis pas un
gourmand de télévision mais je trouve
qu'on a un service public qui est qui
est plutôt de qualité
je pense qu'on aurait plutôt intérêt à
réduire ses chaînes mais au-delà de
cette question qui est technique moi je
ne permettrai pas de deux sur lequel je
me remettrai à l'avancé sur le plan
politique je trouve que cette saillie
vous l'avais déjà dit les désastreuses
on nous annonce la fin de la taxe
d'habitation chaque fois qu'il ya
quelque chose qui peut être ressentie
comme une avancée dans l'esprit des
citoyens parce qu'il ya quelque chose
qui vient et qui lamine la dimension
genre toi en termes de communication
politique je trouve que depuis plusieurs
mois ce gouvernement est désastreux mais
là on est au coeur je crois vraiment au
coeur du des difficultés du gouvernement
actuel c'est-à-dire qu'on nous avait
vendu une transformation et un
changement et nous retrouvons très
exactement tous les travers de ce qu'ils
appellent l'ancien monde mais très
exactement sur tous les sujets et donc
je pense qu'on aimerait c'est à dire
quand ça monte augmenter toujours les
impôts ce serait bien sûr ça typiquement
en matière de politique fiscale en
matière de politique budgétaire le
budget 2010 9 cdu hollande en un peu
mieux ce qui n'est pas déshonorant dans
mon esprit mais c'est dû à l'ordre un
peu mieux ça n'est pas du tout un budget
transformation il ya des choses très
simple à faire il ya des économies à
faire par exemple on a lancé il ya
quelques années france ô à la demande
des députés et sénateurs d'outre-mer qui
voulait que les journaux télévisés
d'outre-mer soit diffusée en france mais
alors c'était une chaîne qui coûtait 3
millions d'euros par an en diffusion est
bien petit à petit on y ajouter des
programmes on est à 30 millions de
pourquoi on sait pas parce que même les
sénateurs et députés de ces régions ne
veulent pas de cette télévision la
france 4 pareil c'était inutile mais on
l'a fait parce que cela dit quand vous
êtes moi j'ai été à l'intérieur de cette
entreprise quand vous dites des choses
comme ça simple on rajoute te tais
simple est beaucoup plus compliqué que
vous l'imaginez
ça veut dire vous avez raison mais vous
étouffez où vous avez la variante qui
essaie beaucoup plus - c'est beaucoup
plus ou moins simple que vous pensez
c'est ça c'est le fait qu' il ya des
choses qui sont évidentes à faire et on
ne les fait pas moi pour moi françois
hausse est synonyme de sa c30 millions
dès que 27 millions d'économies par an
en quelques années cette télévision qui
ne devait rien coûté s'est mis à plat
faire des programmes innues
inutile parce que même pas demandé par
cette population d'outre-mer et savent
tout mais rien contre ça et puis un
dernier élément si vous permettez en
tout cas de mon point de vue c'est que
il ya une suspicion d'une partie de
l'opinion publique sur je dirais la la
liberté la pluralité qui est représenté
sur le service public
quand on apprend récemment que eric
zemmour serait persona non grata sur un
certain nombre de chaînes payé par la
redevance dans les vidéos d'on n'est pas
couché pensez bien qu'évidemment un
certain nombre de contribuables vont
avoir du mal à vouloir et accepté de
gérer de bon coeur à payer une redevance
pour des émissions dans lesquelles ils
se retrouveront absolument pas quelques
réactions sur les réseaux sociaux
et si on privatisait nous dit fable tout
le monde ne serait pas obligé de payer
sur lefigaro.fr cet écrit no 10 je me
dispenserait largement des chaînes
publiques et je suis bien sûr que je ne
suis pas le seul et ce qui at-il encore
d'autres réactions où il ya au livre sur
lefigaro.fr qui nous dit comment ça se
passe dans les autres pays d'europe
je crois que le principe de la redevance
est ce que si a partout en europe alors
ça je ne sais pas je sais pas si
quelqu'un en allemagne j'ai lu cher
qu'en france en grande bretagne elle est
relativement cher oui je crois qu'elle
est plus chère haussière mais le
problème la grande boîte est ce
différent c'est l'histoire de la bbc la
bbc c'est le symbole de l'égalité de la
netteté
c'est un sonne toutes les heures à big
ben donc c'est très différent on a voulu
faire ça mais la radio les taignons
publiquement ce ne sera jamais la bbc
c'est pour ça qu'elle est contesté
parfois et souvent critiqué et pas
toujours à juste à juste titre mais pas
toujours à tort nous fêtons cette
semaine les 60 ans de la constitution de
la vème république qui établissait la
prééminence du chef de l'état élu comme
chacun sait aussi